هذا هو خط الدفاع الأول
لأوكرانيا إذا قررت روسيا الغزو ، ومن
الأساسي أن
نصف دزينة من الجنود في الخنادق المغطاة بالثلوج
لا توجد علامة على وجود أسلحة ثقيلة
على بعد نصف ميل فقط من الانفصاليين المدعومين من روسيا.
تم تجميد هذه الخطوط الأمامية المظلمة
لسنوات ، فإن الهجوم الروسي من شأنه أن يغير
ذلك في لحظة ولكن الإنذار في
واشنطن ليس مشتركًا هنا ،
ما هو مدهش أن نراه هو أنه على الرغم
من تكدس الدبابات والأسلحة الثقيلة
على الجانب الروسي من الحدود
وهو  أقل من 20 ميلاً من هنا على
الجانب الأوكراني ، ليس هناك أي معنى على
الإطلاق أن أي شخص يستعد لغزو
، طلب الرقيب هنا عدم ذكر
اسمه ، فقال إنه لا يتوقع صراعًا
لكنه مستعد ،
أخبرنا قادتنا أننا  يجب أن يكون في
حالة تأهب يخبرنا أننا مستعدون لمقابلة
ضيوف من روسيا ما نوع الأسلحة
التي لديك في هذا الموقع ، هل لديك
أي أسلحة ثقيلة لا أرى أي منها ولكني
أريد فقط أن أمارسها  تأكد من لا في مكان آخر ، فأنت
لست بحاجة إلى رؤيته ولا يحتاج العدو
إلى رؤيته ، كما يقول ، لكن لدينا
كل
ما ليس لديهم هنا ، هناك العديد
من طبقات الدفاع التي
تقود من الأمام ، ولا نرى سوى عدد
قليل من نقاط التفتيش
إذا لم يتمكن الجيش الأوكراني من السيطرة على هذه
المنطقة ، يمكن للقوات الروسية أن تصل إلى ماريوبول ،
وهي مدينة ساحلية يبلغ عدد سكانها نصف مليون في ساعات
على الرغم من التهديد ، تستمر الحياة هنا
كالمعتاد
في الأسواق المحلية الدمى
مفتوحة والأرفف ممتلئة.  لمعرفة ما إذا
كنت تعتقد أنه ستكون هناك حرب ، لا يوجد
فيديو
لدينا أطفال
وأحفاد تقول ناتاليا ولن تكون هناك حرب ،
نعتقد أن
البعض مثل عرجان يقولون إن أمريكا
تبالغ في التهديد
الذي يقول إنه بايدن فقط من يعتقد أن
هذا مثير للاهتمام  التحدث إلى الناس هنا
لا يبدو أن أي شخص يشعر
بالقلق من احتمالية حدوث غزو وشيك ،
هؤلاء الناس ليسوا غرباء عن الحرب في
جميع أنحاء ماريوبول ، بقايا القرى المجوفة التي
دمرت
وهجرها القتال بين أوكراي
القوات النيان والانفصاليين الموالين لروسيا ،
ولكن سواء تحركهم الإنكار أو عدم التصديق ، فإن
هؤلاء الجنود والأشخاص الذين يقومون
بحمايتهم لا يتوقعون أن
يعيد التاريخ نفسه
في الوقت الحالي ، فهم ينتظرون
ويأملون في
كلاريسا عنبر سي إن إن ماريوبول أوكرانيا